it's hi how are you Cheryl nice to see
you again yes and you perform yeah we'll
get you right here he put some big
lights up for the whole thing yeah you
too okay let's go Raptors thank you for
wearing the jersey oh girl looking for
my rap diss Jersey
do you know listen my team was in
Toronto at first because you notice us
to be in Toronto today no I was supposed
to go to the show my husband bought me
to take it in Toronto Toronto but listen
what a great reason not to be in Toronto
so I mean up until like before the last
game I think when I was shall we suck
should we kiss I mean I got so we did it
was the right decision to make
then we were trying to find a Jersey
it's hard to find but you got one and
you look amazing and she's repping right
you also saying a great version of Oh
Canada on your Instagram which we
enjoyed you are just such a light in
this book is just so special well you
know I wanted to do something for the
book because all of the proceeds from
the book I'm not just out here trying to
buy more shoes y'all the book go to the
Boys and Girls Club of Attalla County
Mississippi now you don't know where
that is that's just right down the road
from where I grew up so I started this
boys club I built this boys club like 13
years ago and you know they need money
to sustain it and so that's what I'm
doing I'm out here stumping for the boys
how'd you do how'd you do what did your
path become clearer do you remember a
time in your life I mean yes I do what a
good question one okay great things are
going well my path became clear the
moment I remember it actually when I
flew into Chicago and I was on American
Airlines and I remember looking out the
window and I was thinking to myself this
is going to be my home I'm gonna make my
stake here and I don't even know I
didn't even know if the show was gonna
be successful and I thought if the show
isn't successful then I'm gonna go in
Taizo I'm gonna do something else I'm
gonna figure out a way to make this my
home I remit I remember the moment
that's amazing clear clear clear clear
the little voice inside said this is
going to be it yeah you've made such an
incredible platform for people to just
really help people find themselves and
you've given such amazing talks and
created special moments for people what
do you think your place in this world is
meant for what do you think it is meant
to be an inspiration I'm here to help
other people discover the best of
themselves first I was here to do it for
myself as is every person and then
you're supposed to take what you have
found for yourself whatever that is and
use that to offer to the world and when
you can use whatever it is if it's
making pies if it's being a good friend
if it's being a good listener whatever
it is if you take what you know you have
as your gift and you share it you spread
it around to other people that gift gets
bigger yeah so you know as I often talk
about I started out in the church it's
just like the little girl out there in
church talking people saying oh my girls
show so I can't talk and then taking
that and turning it into a full-blown
you know broadcasting career I did not
know at the time that that's what was
going to happen but I have seen the
pattern for myself right I see the
pattern for you and for everybody else
you tell me what you're doing you tell
me how much you how much that thing
feeds you or doesn't feed you and I can
tell you that the moment you're having
right now is building to the next great
moment that is waiting to come for you
you're gonna make me cry like yeah if
you're just now if you just had here
holding a microphone just because that's
the thing to do to make money that's not
gonna happen but if there's a yearning
inside of you for something more in
something bigger this is the groundwork
for that yeah I know it cuz I've lived
it I've done it I've been on the other
side of it you know what it feels like
right so can we get you back on daytime
everytime at 4 o'clock from meetings in
the living room because I'm just saying
for everybody out there who's I mean we
love super soul Sunday we love all of
these pieces 4 o'clock can we have a
date I would love to make that happen
let me tell you but maybe not every day
that was
our dates were we our dates were too
frequent yeah for 25 years it was
perfect and the only time I missed it
was like you know during the election or
where something really big happens in
the news I think well gee I wish I had a
show but we must you oh thank you thank
you for that thank you for that last
time I saw you you gave me at the bago
for cheryl hickey could you give it to
me again that's perfect thank you